I'm going to start off today's video by
asking you a question and please don't
Google it overwhelmed you just read the
title of the episode,
but it doesn't really matter anyway.
We're betting for you didn't know,
but I can go into with the world's most
expensive country and if you did well,
well done to you.
Well,
when it comes to expensive places to
live,
most people think of New York or Hong
Kong or is uric.
Well,
that's not even close to right.
The world's most expensive sitting is
Luanda the capital city of Angola and
Yep.
That's an African
country.
So rented apartments in Luanda.
You can end up paying over $5,000 a
month.
How about the cost of a big Mac menu?
Mackey,
Ds,
well bounce.
Nineteen American donors and if you want
to have an internet connection at home,
well you better hope you've got a
healthy bank balance because that's
going to cost you around $300 a month.
And they were not kidding.
All right,
so 91,
five.
You wondering what that was going on in
Angola?
Is this some sort of extremely wealthy
country that.
No one knows about.
Well No.
The Republic of Angola is one of the
world's biggest oil exporters,
surpassing other oil rich countries like
Qatar.
Nevertheless,
half of its population has no access to
clean
modern.
Every three children suffer from
malnutrition and one out of every six
dies before reaching five years ago,
a
on the other ends of the spectrum and to
is home to one of the wealthiest women
on the planet.
That would be Isabelle dos Santos,
who by the way is the daughter of former
presidents and Jay said,
sounds awesome.
Yeah.
Might be figuring out what's going on
here.
Oh yes,
I go,
La is one of the most corrupt countries
on the planets.
Indeed,
it was home to one of the biggest
financial fiascos in reason years with
several companies losing billions of
dollars in this country.
While perhaps this is no surprise to
you,
I mean at the end of the day and go,
there is still a third world country.
Nevertheless,
that is a question that must be asked
here.
How did they get here?
How could the country possibly have such
a bizarre economy?
And more importantly,
how is it possible that the ruling party
managers to keep control of this
country?
Well,
today we're going to answer those
questions,
but first we do need to have a look at
it.
Great.
And diplomacy.
First thing we need to understand when
we talk about Africa is the most of the
African countries were colonies in past
centuries.
European
like Belgium,
France and Portugal,
invaded and most of the continents
imposing rules and treating the natives
like animals and go to it wasn't an
exception until 1975.
Portugal made a fortune with its diamond
mines in the country.
Nevertheless,
in that city,
the Portuguese government push to by the
UN and its own people recognized and
Gunas self determination.
And then the question was,
what happens after a country stops being
a colony who takes care of the
governmental affairs after the European
colonizers?
Well,
instead of answering this question by
calling for elections,
the many angerland trines created
different from zen started the civil
war.
Well,
that was a conflict that then when's the
last 25 years?
And there are still parts of the country
today where you call them go because
they're just covered in lamb's mind is
in case you don't know what landmine is,
it is a bomb that you bury underground.
Then when someone steps on,
it explodes as well.
Now you might be wondering how is it
possible that such a poor country could
afford all of these weapons and it was a
big long civil.
Well,
we almost have that one lies in the
diamonds that we previously mentioned.
All signs of the conflict sold diamonds
and in exchange God arms.
But we've provided these arms will often
19,
76.
When true civil war kicks off,
there were two sides.
On the one hand,
there was the units agreed who dominated
the south of the country,
units that were supported by South
Africa,
China,
and to a lesser extent,
the United States,
the days of the Cold War and every war
in any parts of the globe was seen as a
good opportunity to weaken Soviet
influence.
Plus it was known that Angola had oil
reserves.
It's also explains why the Soviet Union
wanted to take part in the conflict too.
They were supporters of the Angolan
People's liberation movements or as they
called it,
the MPLA,
but most of the world leader of the Mpla
was Josie,
Eduardo dos Santos Santos did have the
support of the Soviet Union,
but interestingly,
the country that offered the most
support was actually cute
and we're following our treatment
nationalists duty,
but don't.
Right.
He didn't stop at selling weapons to dos
Santos.
He sends over 30,000 troops to the
country.
Let's not only that,
during the lengthy macy's,
the area that was under the MPLA control
received a lot of doctors and engineers
from Ivana.
This explain.
That's partly why dos Santos one,
the conflict.
In fact,
despite the war still be ongoing during
the 19 nineties,
this man had taken control of most of
the country.
However,
that Cuban help,
well,
it wasn't as useful as you might think.
For example,
the agriculture experts in from Cuba
tried to grow sugarcane on Angolan soil,
but there's apparently those seeds were
not good for the kind of soil that you
find in Angola.
And this
is why within just a few years,
most of the farming lands in the
country,
it became totally infertile.
This meant stole vacation for Angolans
and an anger towards the Cuban help.
Alright,
so as if this really wasn't enough after
the collapse of the Soviet Union at
Water Dot Santos,
realize that it's a good idea to the
friends,
the capitalist country,
at the end of the day,
these were the countries which would buy
their oil.
On the other hand is America was not
helping eunice hair anymore.
So what does this country need to do to
become an ally of the so called free
wealth?
Well,
BEC was only one thing to do when that
was removed the word Marxist from their
vocabulary and swap it out for free
market democracy.
And yes,
I do say that with a touch of sarcasm
because Angolan capitalism.
Well,
that's certainly one of a kind.
You're seeing the Angolan way yet.
Two thousand and two,
it was a turning point in [inaudible]
history.
Eduardo Cental signed the peace
agreements with his adversaries since
then,
unit has become a political party with a
right to run for elections for the first
time in history and garlands.
Could enjoy democracy,
but not so many vast.
In the very same year.
Another meaningful thing
makes burst ultra deep water,
oil discovery off the coast of Angola.
Suddenly I'm Buddha,
became an oil juggernaut selling tons of
dinosaur juice to China in the United
States in just five years.
I can go to the multiplied by four
and go let's.
Capital was being rebuilt.
The varied architecture from the fifties
and sixties is giving way to new office
towers that are being built between the
national corporate sector and then and
government
companies like Exxon mobile in the U.
S or bp and the UK invested heavily in
Angola and of course they sent engineers
and workers to live in the capital.
All the little ones up and of course
these people wanted good quality houses,
cool bars and these same kinds of goods
that they could fly back home.
But all of those things that have the
fines in the country that years,
the fort was having a big old civil war.
In other words,
the supply was small man's yet the
demand.
We didn't stop growing.
As a result,
the prices of Western goods went
absolutely sky high,
built for 500,000 people.
The angerland capitalists now
accommodating an estimated 5 million.
Even civil servants with comfortable
salaries have
well making ends meet was wait just a
minute because there's more.
Imagine we have a construction company
in China and we want to build a housing
block in new enza.
Well,
the first thing we want to do is
register a company,
right?
Well,
that process can take six months during
that time.
That's perfectly normal that the
government fines and lots of problems
and they ask me for this paper,
that registry,
and that's how the report that you
probably don't have the sort of report
that a nice stack of cash and they do a
sweaty palm under a table,
could probably
and
does have a reports made by
organizations like Transparency
International.
Almost every company who does business
in Angola has had to do with some sort
of bribery.
The government's official,
but wait just a minute because this is
still not the end of it.
Those oil companies like Exxon Mobil or
British Petroleum that we're willing to
do business in Angola as they were,
had to establish partnerships with the
government or so and goal the Angola
state
company
now have a guest who is the head of that
company.
Well,
and yes,
that was all friend we mentioned
earlier,
Isabelle dos Santos,
the daughter of the former presidents of
the country.
This explains why Isabelle tell became
the wealthiest women in Africa in so
every major Angolan investment held by
dos Santos stemmed from taking a chunk
of a company that wants to do business
in the country or from a stroke of the
president's pen that cut her into the
action
for all of this.
On the governments have dos Santos,
the father of restricted access to the
country for international journalists.
In fact,
most of the corruption scandals,
we know what else I've been discovered
by the governments of the US.
Okay.
Of course,
with a political kind of like this,
no,
I can go then wanted to start a company,
but at the end of the day,
the reality was that you needed to be a
millionaire in order to pay those
barriers.
Brian's men's.
Even if we would put the cost of bribery
aside just with the basic bureaucracy,
you need a thousand US dollars to start
a normal bar in windsor in the country,
as poor as I can get under a thousand
dollars isn't absolutely not only that,
these international companies were not
willing to invest in the country more
than the absolute minimum required
to extract the oil.
So now you might wonder what were the
consequences of all this well outcome is
that dinosaur juice is the only and
Golan export back in the last decade,
the only new and Golan businesses were
crude oil extraction plants and houses
for its workers.
By the year 2014 oil represented 97
percent of end goal exports.
No.
This point,
if you're a regular visual politic via
you might be thinking,
this sounds pretty familiar to me.
That's probably because you've seen on
videos on Venezuela,
a country with a similar economic
system.
John's like,
what happens in Nicolas?
Maduro has country.
When the oil market price went down,
then Garla went right along with it.
So now let's get onto the example of the
Chinese construction companies.
Many companies from China invested
millions building entire neighborhoods,
facts that professionals coming to the
country,
but now there's no more oil industry
then therefore there's no more workers.
Four lane highways without cause schools
with no pupils and under five years a
Chinese company built Columbia using oil
credit lines with China,
but parts of Columbia,
I feel like a ghost town in summary,
that is only
one winner in that story,
and that person is who sandwell dude or
Santos and his daughter Isabelle,
who has already invested these enormous
profits overseas.
Most of the big Portuguese firms from
galp to Unitel.
Now under the control of this family.
If Portugal was a colonizer in the past,
well,
they've now become Angola's money
launderer out and golden elites have
sent an estimated $119,000,000,000 out
of the country.
And while the entire country is having a
crisis,
Isabelle dos Santos,
who identifies herself as entrepreneur
on our twitter account,
goes out with celebrities like Kim
called Dashi,
and all of this being said,
you might have guessed the dos Santos
family is not that popular here.
Now you go there,
right?
Really,
in fact,
that political party,
the MPLA keeps stealing the show
election after election getting over 70
percent of the votes this past August
2017.
Angola held an electric despite the fact
that juice Eduardo Dot Santos was not a
does anymore.
His party at one end game.
I'm so now you might be wondering,
well,
why does this happen?
Well,
I'm afraid that we're probably never
going to need rejects.
EU election observers.
And now the question really becomes,
is it going to be possible for Angola to
get rid of this corrupt ruling class?
Can lead follow the trends of those
African lions like gone or older ones
that.
Well,
let us know what you think in the
comments.
By the way,
I'd like to recommend another political
channel,
which has great information about
geopolitics.
If you're like us,
you like them,
do check out the Caspian report.
You can find a link in the description
and also don't forget to check out the
reconsider media podcast.
They provide the vocals in this episode
that are not mine,
and don't forget to subscribe to this
channel.
We put our brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday,
so do you subscribe to get those and
there's always.
I'll see you in the next video
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my love
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.